my guest tonight is a writer an actor
who's recently been seen in the film's
Little Women and the post he currently
produces the stars in the acclaimed AMC
series better call Saul and on top of
all that is one of the funniest people
I've ever met please welcome Bob
Odenkirk Bob good to see you hey come in
how are you I'm doing pretty well you
know there's a lot to talk about here
and these are really strange times and
then I just found out that you have had
a personal brush with this coronavirus
madness yeah my son Nate who's 21 was at
DePaul and his roommate was sick really
really sick and my son had asthma for
many years and very bad I mean a lot of
times that goes away around 18 or so but
he he was even at 20 and I think he
still uses an inhaler sometimes so when
I met him at the airport
and I gave him a mask and you know he
washed his hands with antibacterial soap
and all that stuff and he woke up the
next morning with a fever and he said
his throat hurt like it had cancer and
he said it really hurt and he said he
was debilitated for weeks right two
weeks pretty much two weeks you know to
the point where we're just so used to
the flu and we can't our brains just
naturally go oh come on I've been
through it I get it three days two three
days that are hard and then you get
better and it's just not that it's not
that it's much worse and yeah so two
weeks in he's still I'm like looking at
him I'm going you're you're good now
right you you're doing good right and
he's like no no I'm not good it's like
the power of positive thinking I know
that thing where you're trying to you're
trying to will people to be better like
yeah you look you look fine right no no
how many feet you have I'm seeing two
feet I'm seeing arms moving around you
and I spent if you added up the number
of the amount of time that you and I
spent
we were young in rooms together being
complete asses and making each other
laugh it would it would amount to like
weeks and weeks and weeks of solid time
and it was all pure idiocy pure
foolishness those are very happy
memories for me so it's been very
satisfying for me to have see you have
not only this really amazing comedy
career but tonight it's the better call
Saul fifth season finale next season is
going to be a full season that that
brings us to the you know the real and
yeah is actually in a weird way the
beginning because it's the beginning of
your character and the story of Breaking
Bad
I think they'll also tell the story of
how this guy puts his life back together
after he's gone into hiding after
Breaking Bad I think yeah but I don't
you know I never know what to believe
from Vince Gilligan and Peter Gould the
writers who lead this show when they
oftentimes say they had no plan in place
you know they often in interviews say I
had no idea what this would mean or who
who this character would turn out to be
I think they're I guess hard to believe
that they don't have an inkling of where
all this goes because there's no way and
it's like a Swiss watch the way they put
this together so watch Jimmy McGill over
these past number of seasons slowly
start to morph into Saul yeah you know
it was it's been an amazing fun journey
to discover this character Saul Goodman
Jimmy McGill and and I like the guy as
Jimmy I don't like a mess all yeah it's
still fun to watch him be this clown and
get into all kinds of trouble because of
it but the real mystery of the show now
is Kim Wexler played by Ray Sehorn she's
hard to and and when people see this
final episode of season five which I
watched yesterday boy it ends completely
on her and the question of who she
really is inside
I think we all have different personas
we are at work and at home and then with
our significant others and then even
alone now I'm always the same oh jesus
your poor wife really in bed guys I'm
always doing takes like huh and it's
like all the time
all the time yeah so I don't know what
you're talking about and somehow and
somehow you have two kids yeah yeah they
don't look anything like me I ran into
vince gilligan
recently I went to this is long before
the coronavirus went back when we went
to plays and my wife and I went to a
play and Vince was sitting in front of
us just being a real jerk making a lot
of noise yeah that's him it was one of
the sweetest genteel people I've ever
met I was talking to him a little bit
and then he said something really
interesting he said that he thinks if
you as a method actor do you think
that's true I guess
Vince is probably talking about the fact
that I'm very willing you know there's a
scene in a dumpster in the first season
you know this episode episode 8 of this
season which Vince directed and it's a
masterpiece and Conan if you only watch
one episode from season five watch
season watch episode five oh eight it's
really amazing and but like I'm crawling
in the in the sand and basically I'm
gonna say let me crawl every time it's
okay as long as I'm not bleeding too
much I this is what the characters going
through so it only helps me to actually
do it it says I drew a line at drinking
my own pee yeah I didn't think I needed
to do that to pretend that I drank my
pee and how or maybe in my past I've
drank a lot of pee and I just don't need
you channeled that time well in acting
class the first thing you do is drink
your own pee and you got to do it so
just so you're able to play that scene
one day in Hamlet you know the hamlet in
Hamlet where they drink pee I was gonna
ask you about you know Chris Farley who
we all worked with and knew you worked
with him very closely in second city and
I know a bunch of people know this but I
don't know if everybody knows that you
created his motivational speaker
character Matt Foley I wanted to ask you
about that process of coming up with
that character and writing it out for
Chris Farley how did that come about we
were rehearsing and and improvising
scenes after the main stage show and we
did some improvisation where we were
doing like an anti-drug speech to
students and it was improvised we were
goofing around and Chris did a version
of Matt Foley he didn't have the glasses
or the suit but he was just hectoring
the kids with that empty you know by
golly you kids are gonna get it together
you know it was just that voice of a
coach who's just really doesn't know
what he's saying and is but it's trying
to put a lot of emphasis in it and and I
just went home with that voice in my
head it was very funny and these I sat
down with a legal pad and and wrote up
that sketch exactly the way it's done
although Robert Smigel added him
smashing the table at Saturday Night
Live because we didn't do that at Second
City
well you City he marched out the door
and everybody ran for the exits so that
they wouldn't be there when he got back
but so then I brought it in the next day
and holy crap Chris I mean it was just
amazing how it it just came to life and
filled that theater every night my
daughter asked me once what was the the
most fun you ever had doing what you do
and and I told her and I still I think I
still believe it would be the eight
shows a week with Chris
doing the motivational speaker because
you know I've never seen anything hit so
hard every time and Chris wouldn't leave
the stage until he made all the
performers laugh that was he was driven
to make you laugh when he did the sketch
every single night so he'd be throwing
in different things he'd come right in
your face pushing his glasses up and it
was the greatest it was pure awesomeness
well I want to make sure I want to make
sure that I end with this you know
usually they'll say well you're to be
talking to so-and-so and they have a
clip and I would say maybe 70% of the
time the clip is kind of underwhelming
if you're talking to an actor or it's
not often even as good as the show
itself you guys sent along a clip that
is riveting I know we're gonna sort of
show a little bit of a condensed version
of it but this clip is one of my it's
just one of the best clips I've seen in
a long time it's got an amazing stunt in
it we're in the desert this is episode
508 this wonderful episode directed by
Vince Gilligan and we all suffered a lot
to make it and the characters are
suffering in it and I can we talk about
it for a second after let's watch it
let's show it and roll it
come on I'm just walking here ah sweet
Guardium idiot
[Music]
yeah it is I just want to say the driver
of that truck is Cory Eubanks he's one
of the best if not the best stunt driver
in the world and Cory is a super nice
guy and if you've seen a car flip in any
movie of the last ten years he's
probably in it and in fact I showed that
clip to stunt people and they said is
that Cory Eubanks in there that without
seeing him
right they can tell by the way flips a
truck it says crazy stunt but it's an
amazing it's it's a very tense scene and
I'm sure anyone who hasn't completely
caught up with better call Saul will be
if they just see a second of that clip
will be like all right time to catch up
well make sure I get the word out the
season five finale of better call Saul
aired tonight on AMC all episodes from
the fifth season of better call Saul are
available to watch on AMC comm and it is
absolutely superb
so congratulations Bob thanks buddy
another great season and thank you so
much for talking to me and I really do
send you the best wishes for your son I
hope he's feeling better he's great and
thank you for sharing that personal your
personal touch with all of this because
I think that's very helpful for people
to pick up on who are watching right now
yeah
all right well everybody stay safe and
thanks Conan it's great to see you great
to see you too thank you very much Bob
and take care all right take care